Film Courage: When you plan on shooting it
[Keith’s next film], what do you think you
will do differently?
What are some things that you learned from
say if a location that fell through, etc.?
Keith Sutliff, Filmmaker: Well, I would have
hired more people, I mean ideally.
I think on the budget, I needed more people.
Bigger crew, more people in pre-production
helping and in post production.
So definitely more people.
That’s really about it.
The bigger the team, the bigger the army you
have, the easier it is for you as a producer
on the film.
So you’re not juggling too many hats.
You have people helping out.
So essentially just hiring more people and
delegating these duties and jobs to these
other people.
Film Courage: Do you like to do a lot of stuff
yourself?
You know there are certain people, they love
to be really hands-on.
Keith Sutliff: I do.
I do.
I did a lot of editing on this last one.
I had an editor but I did a lot of editing
on THE MASON BROTHERS.
My editor and I were writing it but I did
do a lot of editing on it.
That was very tedious.
I edited a lot of stuff like the trailers
and some little things, promotional stuff.
I think editing is…I don’t say I hate
the most, but it’s very tedious and time
consuming out of all the things.
That’s why I told my team “Hey this next
one, there’s no way.”
I’ll edit maybe the beginnings and may help
out on the trailers but obviously I’ll let
someone edit the rest.
I’ll give them the notes on how I kind of
want it.
On this last one I was doing like, maybe 35%
of the scenes I was editing and like the other
30-35%, I was telling my editor what I wanted
and stuff.
I let him edit like 35% and it was a lot of
dialogue because there were some complex scenes
in there, what were like bad scenes, something
like that where it had to be edited a certain
way I had in mind because I thought of my
shot list (what I came up with my cinematographer)
that just from studying films for so long,
it’s hard to explain to somebody like "Hey
when something bad happens in the movie, the
camera needs to flip to this angel over here
to show this reaction of the actors face and
hide the instrument” or whatever.
Instead of explaining that, it’s kind of
easier just to do it because you’ve seen
it in films and how you want the shot that
you developed.
So it was a lot of hands on with that, but
for the next one it’s too time-consuming.
I’ll let someone just do it and I’ll correct
them with notes or whatever.
Film Courage: What are you using to edit on?
Keith Sutliff: Adobe Premiere.
It’s a good program.
My editor had a big personal computer.
I know a lot of people edit off of Macintosh
computers, but he had a huge PC station.
That’s what we edited on and a lot of it
was done with Adobe.
Film Courage: And you taught yourself how
to use Adobe Creative Suite [a.k.a Creative
Cloud]?
Keith Sutliff: Actually I learned it in my
filmmaking classes.
We started editing on everything in Adobe.
From all the things we shot we learned from
the computers in the lab how to edit from
the Professor.
Alex Pickering is a great professor from USC
and he teaches the course in East LA.
He was teaching how to edit and we just learned
from the courses and materials and the guides.
They had these little CD-roms and kind of
walk you though stuff.
That’s what I learned and I just went from
there.